[Music]
we're gonna pick up where we stopped on
our previous message we were talking
about this mystery of godliness which is
Christ in us the hope of glory if that's
the mystery of godliness than we have
seen that the mystery of iniquity is
Satan and fallen angels manifesting in
people's lives one of the questions that
has been presented in my heart in my
mind as well as many others is why
pantheism we've seen in the previous
three messages that the route of
spiritual formation is pantheism but why
the word pantheism literally means God
is in all things he is in the chair the
floor the tree the rock the plant the
food you eat the water do you drink the
air you breathe and he's also in every
human being I can remember when I was in
in the martial arts and I was training
especially as I was working higher
levels you know we were told to go out
and we would stand in front of a tree
that was a very strong tree like an
evergreen or an oak tree or a hickory
tree but you wanted one that was strong
that didn't have decay and you would
stand there for hours and a certain pose
and sometimes the post would look like
this and you would hold your hands up
and you would just meditate and stay
there in that position picturing in your
mind that you were absorbing this energy
from this tree and people go I mean how
could you do that that's foolish well
after you do it if you believe you begin
to feel something literally you would
start feeling energized I mean you would
feel like 10
and and strength and all this vitality
coming into you but I did not realize it
was evil spirits that were causing those
feelings it's not like people are just
crazy when they do that stuff there are
manifestations but why pantheism
pantheism when you say that God is in
everything that also means that God is
already inside of every human being so
now instead of looking upward for
salvation instead of looking to God's
Word for the spirit and power you're
being taught to look inward
if God's inside there then why do I need
to go to a book to find him so weird
people are being taught to look inward
and there's a reason for that because
when people are taught to look inward
they begin going to those religions and
those practices that focus inward which
are all the eastern practices that come
along with spiritual formation I'm going
to show you some quotes and these are
all from Buddhist or Hindu or Taoist or
Shinto martial artists or internal
artists like Tai Chi or ki Gong this is
a man named Forrest E Morgan he's a
military American military he said a
true Budo aspirant devotes himself to a
system of physical mental and spiritual
discipline through which he attempts to
elevate himself in search of perfection
we just read in the last message Isaiah
chapter 14 Satan said I will exalt
myself he says the same thing he said
this practice of Budo or bushi
martial arts he said it is an attempt to
elevate oneself in search of perfection
Satan is using these Eastern practices
as a counterfeit of the true
he says martial arts are legendary for
the seemingly mystical powers they teach
you will learn what forces Warriors
really command more importantly you'll
learn how to develop them yourself this
is something that was startling you
remember the very first message and the
second one and the third one we talked
about making a note of the word nature
we really emphasized that make a note of
the word nature Zen Buddhism Zen is what
it's called in Japan and Okinawa in
China it's called Chan Buddhism same
thing but it's a different pronunciation
this is the actual definition from the
Encyclopedia Brittanica Chan Buddhism or
Zen is a religious sect derived from the
Hindu word meaning a process of
meditation that is used to achieve an
awakening to the Buddha nature when
people talk about Zen that's what the
purpose of Zen is to enlighten you and
awaken you to the Buddha nature do you
understand now why those things are
being used by Satan and being brought
into churches even in our own
denomination I cannot tell you how many
people have written to me and said we've
got the bringing tai chi classes into
our seventh-day adventist church
they're bringing in karate classes and
Taekwondo classes and ki Gong classes
and yoga classes into churches and they
don't realize what it is doing it's
caught
people to lose faith in God's Word it's
opening the door of the house of God to
demonic power
this was another Japanese master in the
fifteen and 1600s he said once you have
trained yourself well your body and
limbs will move automatically without
any conscious effort that's scary you're
talking about possession if your arms
and limbs are moving without you having
to tell them to either there's a
physical problem like a disease like
epilepsy or though you're having a
seizure or you have possession he said
your mind will not be overwhelmed by
your physical movements you will employ
techniques unconsciously without having
to think would you want your son and
daughter or your husband and wife to
come home and do things without having
to think about them I mean what if you
just reacted I mean I can remember when
I was in the martial arts I mean
somebody would come up sometimes in
touch you and you would react without
thinking and you never want to do that
you never want to do that because what
if you react to the wrong person
what if somebody came up and they
touched you on the back and you turn
around and strike and you find out that
your mom or your dad or your wife or
your child he said once you have
achieved this state not a single doubt
or hesitation will arise train yourself
thoroughly and then forget about it
throw away your mind
that's his exact quote what that means
is is you're conscious when you throw
your mind away that's called emptying
the mind that's right that means I I
step out of the driver's seat of the car
and I let something else begin to steer
my life for me throw away your mind you
will then follow the way and that's what
Bushido
is they call it the way do you remember
what Jesus said I am the way the truth
and the life
he says throw away your mind you will
then follow the way without being aware
of it this is the mystery of Bushido
that's his words that was in the
fifteenth and 1600s and I guarantee you
that man had probably never read the
Bible Thomas white he's a tenth dawn
listen to what he said karate is not
something that one does it is something
that one becomes the word karate in
Okinawan or in Japanese it means empty
hand and I had a question that came to
my mind one day why did they say it's
empty hand and they say was because
you're not using weapons well then why
do they train with weapons they use
swords and staffs and sighs and and all
cut nunchucks and all kinds of weapons
so it has to have another meaning
besides that and then one day the Lord
revealed it to me an empty hand means my
mind is not controlling the hand anymore
it means something else is controlling
the hand my mind is not there an empty
hand means a hand that is possessed by
another an empty mind is a mind that is
possessed by another he says although
and though the external mask of training
might be readily seen in the lighted
arena
the essence pay attention to that word
the essence of karate dough is ever the
veiled presence of being and that that
made me think
Christ veiled his who is deity with
humanity
he said the essence of karate as ever
the veiled presence
of being the question I had was of what
being the veiled presence of what being
who is it that is veiled behind the
flesh of those men and women that are
you know participating in this listen to
what the father of modern-day karate
said gichin funakoshi
you may train for a long time but if you
merely move your hands and feet and jump
up and down like a puppet then learning
karate is not very different from
learning the dance you will never have
reached the heart of the matter you will
have failed to grasp the quintessence of
carotids oh that word quintessence I
want to show you what that means because
we don't hear that word very often in
our modern age this is what Webster's
dictionary says quintessence it is the
fifth and highest element in the ancient
and medieval thought philosophy that is
said to permeate all nature and it is
the substance composing all the
celestial bodies in physics it is a
hypothetical form of dark energy that's
Webster's dictionary the fifth
fundamental force the fifth element by
the ancient Greeks it was this force
which was thought to fill the universe
and hold all things together that's
pantheism that's exactly what we just
heard from Star Wars the other night
when we were revealing this they say may
the force be with you and you look at
Star Wars and the good guys the Jedi
they use the Force and the bad guys the
Sith they use the Force so the same
power is used by one group for
supposedly good things
and it's used by another group for
supposedly evil things now some people
say I've never seen Star Wars well let
me go back a few years have you ever
seen The Wizard of Oz I guarantee almost
every American has seen it almost do you
remember the Wicked Witch from the West
she had a long crooked nose and green
skin and she was ugly and had black hair
and I mean you know she was evil
obviously and then you had the Good
Witch of the East and she had a
beautiful pink gown on and beautiful
hair blond hair and nice makeup but they
were both witches they both depended on
the same power to do what they did
they're both witches just because one
dress is different than the other
doesn't make one better than the other
they're both using witchcraft and
sorcery listen to what this master said
he passed away just a couple of years
ago he was a master in Australia named
Earl Montague he said some call this the
power of God others call it universal
power and many a genius has talked about
the elusive other 90% of the brain that
we never use but it is my belief and
experience that the power comes from
other sources from around the body but
very close to it and attached to it in
traditional Chinese medicine this is
called shin or spirit and it is this
power that we are able to tap into to
change our physical circumstances to
stop others from attacking us and to
cause others to do what you wish them to
do just as long as it is positive and
good well who
besides if it's positive for good he's
using this power to cause other people
to do what he wants them to do and in
the martial arts that was used heavily
in yoga in traditional Chinese medicine
in acupuncture and key Gong all of those
Eastern arts depend on this same power
all of them they won't tell little
Johnny and Susie's parents that when
they first signed up at Taekwondo plus
but you talked to a man that's a second
or third degree black belt or talk to
one of the Masters and they'll tell you
very clearly listen to what Ellen White
said our condition through sin is
unnatural and the power that restores us
must be supernatural else it has no
value there is but one power that can
break the hold of evil from the hearts
of men and that is the power of God in
Christ Jesus the power of God look that
word God up when you get home the Greek
word is Theo's it means deity and
divinity it's the only two definitions
I'm not saying God is not a being I
don't want to be missed
misunderstood but it was the power of
God in Christ that sets us free jesus
said that in John chapter 14 when Philip
came to him and he said Lord show us the
father and it sufficeth us and she's a
sin if I've been so long time with you
and you have not seen me or known me and
Philip you know looked at him and he was
like I don't understand and then in
verse 10 and 11 Jesus said something he
said
the words that I'm speaking to you it's
not me speaking them it's my father that
dwells inside of me he's doing the works
do you know that's all through the Old
Testament even in Isaiah chapter 26
verse 12 I believe it's verse 12 God
actually says he has wrought all of our
works in us and there's something
beautiful that I want to show you all
that towards the the close of this
series but we're gonna wait to get there
only through the blood of the Crucified
one is there cleansing from sin have you
ever wondered how that's possible how
does Jesus's blood cleanse me from sin I
mean like literally literally how does
his blood cleanse me from all sin
Leviticus tells us in Leviticus 17 were
not to eat blood because the life is in
the blood so when Jesus poured out his
blood for us on Calvary he was pouring
out his life Romans chapter 6 verse 10
says that when he died he died unto sin
and the Bible says that if we were in
him when he died rather than sinning you
and I also died rather than sinning and
what he wants for us now is to simply
take hold of that and say I'm his
Ephesians chapter 1 verse 4 says we were
chosen in him before the foundation of
the world so that we should be holy and
without blame before him in love and
we're gonna have we are going to have
more quotes that we're going to show I'm
not asking you to to just take this and
believe it because I'm saying it but I
want you to start looking read the first
two chapters of the Ephesians this week
and highlight or mark down on a piece of
paper every single time you can find the
phrase in Christ in whom or in him or in
me it's all through the Bible once you
read the first two chapters of Ephesians
and you mark it down you'll see it
everywhere Isaiah chapter 45 verse 22
through 25
jesus speaking said look unto me and be
ye saved all the ends of the earth for I
am God and there is none else and in the
Gospels he said I and my father are one
we're one he is in me and I am in him
John 17 he said the same thing father I
pray that they all might be one as I am
in you and as you are in me that they
also might be one in us only through the
blood of the Crucified one as they're
cleansing from sin his grace alone can
enable us to resist and subdue the
tendencies of our fallen nature the
spiritualistic theories concerning God
make His grace His divine influence of
no effect for if God is an essence
pervading all nature then he dwells in
all men and in order to attain holiness
man has only to develop the power within
himself these theories if followed to
their logical conclusion do away with
the necessity for the atonement and they
make man his own Savior and I want you
to also look this up at Ellen White's
writings where she talks about atonement
you will you will not believe how many
times she talks about the fact that the
atonement was made at Calvary atonement
at one mint was made at Calvary Christ
United humanity with God again do you
know the only thing that ever separated
us from God sin right when when men
would go into the Old Testament
sanctuary there was a veil and the sin
of the sinner was placed upon an
innocent lamb for example there were
other offerings but we used the lamb for
now and that lamb its throat was cut its
blood was spilled which now contained
the sin that blood was taken into the
sanctuary and it was sprinkled on
different articles depending on the
circumstances but then it was sprinkled
upon and before the veil do you know
that sister white said that the veil was
torn down every single year on the day
of atonement and it had to be replaced
do you know why it smelled I mean can
you imagine what it would be like if you
left a steak or something sitting out
raw in the kitchen for three weeks it
would I mean it would it would be
terrible that's why the sanctuary had to
be cleansed and on the day of atonement
our Savior went through the veil and he
made atonement for the holy place in the
Old Testament the holy place also had
another name it was called the
tabernacle of the congregation that
sanctuary which desire they just talks
about was a picture of us you had the
holy place which was man and then you
had the most holy place which was God
and you had a veil that separated
between us
and then you read Hebrews chapter 10 and
see what it says that veil was a symbol
of it says it was Christ's flesh
it was his flesh Peter says in 1st Peter
chapter 2 that he bore all of our sins
in his own body upon the tree
that's what Colossians talks about when
it says he nailed that which was against
us to the tree taking it out of the way
he took away our sins so that now we
could be united with God and through the
impartation of his holy spirit we could
have victory amen we will cover more of
that as we go because the devil's doing
everything he can to hide this these
theories regarding God make his word of
no effect and those who accept them are
in great danger of being finally led to
look upon the whole Bible as a fiction
they may regard virtue as being better
than Vice but having shut out God from
his rightful position of sovereignty
they place their dependence upon human
power which without God is worthless it
says they shut out God from his rightful
position of sovereignty when we say the
phrase the Lord Jesus Christ the word
Lord in the Old Testament if it was
capital L with a little ard the word in
Hebrew was Adonai we're not saved by
pronunciation or knowing the Hebrew
language okay but it's beautiful to
understand what a word means because it
helps give us a better understanding of
what the scripture is really telling us
it's like going to a friend of yours and
and them saying yeah but it says hell
right here and you go yeah but that word
in Greek means the grave
or in Hebrew it means the grave by you
understanding what that word means it
makes the passage become clearer by
understanding that the word Lord is
Adonai that word literally means the
sovereign king the Lord Jesus Christ
means the king Jesus Christ that's why
he looks to each of us and says I know
you want to Savior but are you willing
to have a king a king saves people a
king fights for people he delivers
people he sense captives free that's why
Jesus said all power in heaven and on
earth is now given unto me go proclaim
the glad tidings all through the Gospels
when you read it says I remember the
first time I was reading after I'd come
back to the Lord and he had set me free
and I was just like lord I want to just
start in Matthew and I want to go
through the whole New Testament and then
the whole old and I started in Matthew
and Mark and I got I kept seeing this
phrase John the Baptist said repent the
kingdom of heaven is at hand and in my
mind I thought no wait a minute the
kingdom of heaven is at hand that was
2000 years ago in my mind I thought the
kingdom of heaven was Christ's second
coming and I thought well John the
Baptist was the greatest of prophets was
he just did he just not see clearly and
then the next chapter or two I read
Jesus say the same thing after his
baptism Jesus went proclaiming the
kingdom of God and I thought why no
Jesus wasn't mistaken and the Lord spoke
to me like he has done a few times he
was like Eric you've never even looked
the word kingdom up look it up and I
looked it up and you know what the word
kingdom means the sovereign king or
reign of God the kingdom is at hand
that's the glad tidings that he wants
for us to go share with the world you
don't have to be in bondage to sin sin
does not have dominion over you anymore
if you will confess that and give it to
the Lord Jesus Christ he will take your
sins and give you his righteousness sin
will not have dominion over you anymore
now you have a new king on the throne of
your life now I want you to hear this
this is from desire of Ages page 3:11
God's ideal for his children is higher
than the highest human thought can reach
for our Lord our King has said be ye
therefore perfect even as your father
which is in heaven is perfect now I want
you to think about that for a minute
look at that phrase be ye he didn't say
try to be he didn't say strive with all
your might and I've had people tell me
well it doesn't really mean that it
means he knows you're humans to do the
best you can as a human being like he
does the best he can as God that's
foolishness jesus said be ye who was it
that created everything in Genesis it
was Christ it was God in Christ and
through Christ but it was Christ what
was the first statement of Genesis
chapter 1 let there be light and there
was he didn't say let there be light and
a group of angels get together and say
we need to form a committee and we need
to have some drawings made and we need
to get together the equipment to make
this law
and we need the raw materials and okay
Lord it's going to take us five years
and we'll have light for you that's not
what happened
God spoke and it was and here Jesus says
the same thing be ye therefore perfect
and listen to what Ellen White says this
is her words this command is a promise
that's what she said in education 1:26
every command is a promise this command
to be e therefore perfect is a promise
for the plan of redemption contemplates
our complete recovery from the power of
Satan Christ always separates the
contrite soul from sin he came to
destroy the works of the devil and he
has made provision so that the Holy
Spirit shall be imparted to every
repentant soul to keep you from sinning
that's powerful we've not even gotten
there yet we're only on the second night
and you wait I cannot I want to skip to
the end
if y'all only knew how hard this is
listen to this study the Scriptures for
the words I speak unto you jesus said
they are spirit in their life study the
Scriptures know that the only thing in
which we can safely glory is that which
will open to you the gates of the City
of God that's the righteousness of
Christ now I'm going to pause there for
a moment because I want you to know
something there's another statement
Ellen White said she said the
requirements for eternal life under the
New Covenant are the same as they were
under the old they've always been the
same the requirements for
eternal life our perfect obedience so
you know what I thought growing up even
over the last ten years
I've got to be perfect I've got a I've
got a dot every I and cross every T and
and do you know what God revealed to me
Eric if you never sinned again from this
day forward you still don't have perfect
obedience because if you have ever
fallen once you're out of the game do
you understand
if you commit one you're guilty of all
it's not three strikes you're out it's
one strike if I go to get a job at UPS
and they say Eric have you ever gotten a
traffic ticket and in my mind I go man I
mean that was five years dollars no I
don't have any record of any traffic
tickets and they say okay we'll give us
a few days and we'll get back to you
about your you know your resume and they
call me back and they say we need you to
come in and I come in they say listen
everything else we checked out was
perfect but you lied to us I'm like nope
I didn't they said you told us you
didn't you had never had a traffic
violation I said I've paid for them
they've been paid for I don't owe any
debt and they're like that's not what we
asked we asked if you have ever been
guilty and I'm like yeah but I think
that's what you meant the requirements
for eternal life are perfect obedience
with no failure do you understand what
happened in 1888 while the majority of
our church rejected the message of
righteousness by faith they had in their
minds like many of us do I'm gonna try
really hard and if I can get everything
done perfectly you know somebody comes
along they say you know you need to be
vegan you know you need to
start keeping Sabbath earlier you know
you forgot about this and we make this
list of things and we're striving for
something that we will never attain
because if you've already failed once
you're out the thief on the cross
understood that that's why he cast
himself on Christ all to you I bring
simply to your cross I cling its Christ
and His righteousness alone now I'm not
saying that does away with us striving
to obey
I want to obey Him because of what he's
done for me
not in order to gain him doing something
for me
the Bible says that when we were yet
without strength when we hated God
Christ died for us
then when we were at our very worst and
then Paul goes on and he says if he did
that for you when you were at your worst
why do you think he would do less now
that you're striving to obey learn from
the Word of God how to form characters
fitted for the country you are seeking
know that Christ is to be set forth
among you that means in your midst in
your heart and that all that was lost in
Adam the cross of Christ fully restores
to every believing soul I don't have
this quote up here I wish I had Ellen
White said the moment the sinner lays
hold on Christ by faith that moment his
sins are no longer upon him he stands
guiltless before the law of God clothed
in the righteousness of Christ that
moment the moment you believe what God's
Word said the blood of Jesus cleanses me
from all sin not by works of
righteousness which we have done but
according to his
mercy he saved us past-tense
by the washing of regeneration and the
renewing of his holy spirit the life of
Christ that gives life to the world is
in his word it was by his word that
jesus healed disease and cast out demons
by his word he stilled the sea and
raised the dead and the people bore
witness that his word was with power do
you remember that man at the Pool of
Bethesda read that story and desire of
Ages read it in the Gospels and then
read it in desire of Ages she said that
if he had had told the Lord if you'll
heal me I'll get up and walk he would
have stayed there until he died he
believed what Christ said he believed
the power in Christ Word and He willed
to walk he made the decision I'm going
to stand up because Christ has told me
to and he cannot lie and because he
believed the power was given to him the
whole Bible is a manifestation of Christ
and the Savior desired to fix the faith
of his followers on the word when his
visible presence should be withdrawn the
word must be their source of power like
their master they were we are to live by
every word that proceedeth out of the
mouth of God what is justification by
faith it is the work of God in laying
the glory of man in the dust do you want
to know what all these Eastern practices
do they teach you to glory in your power
look what I can do look what I did that
was the problem with the Pharisee
while I did this and you know it's like
you know okay I get victory over this
one since oh I'm forcing that victory on
everybody else
I remember one time I had a lady that
called me and she had learned some truth
in the Bible and she was like you know
Wow
and she went to share it with a friend
of hers and the gentleman he couldn't
see it and she called and she was like I
don't know what to do she said I guess I
just need to do what the Bible says and
shake the dust off my feet and move on
and I thought and I've done the same
thing but I thought Oh Lord
what if Jesus had done that to me I'm
shaking the dust off my feet I'm done
with their coming I've tried you know
this is 49 times this month I'm not
there's no 50 jesus said if you had only
understood what this meaneth I would
have mercy and not sacrifice you know
what I told that lady I asked God I said
give me the words to say to her I asked
her a question I said how long did it
take you to fully understand and
comprehend the truth that you now have
and she said oh probably 16 18 years I
said then be willing to give your
brother in Christ the same time to
comprehend be patient
pray instead of trying to force someone
to believe pray prayer availeth much
when men see their own nothingness only
then they are prepared to be clothed
with the righteousness of Christ when
they begin to praise and exalt God all
the day long then by beholding they are
becoming changed into the same image
what is regeneration it is revealing to
man what is his own real nature that in
himself he is worthless that's scary
do you understand this is what was being
proclaimed in 1888 men don't want to
hear that women don't want to hear that
nobody wants to hear that but praise God
I have never found more freedom than in
knowing that god I am filthy and
wretched and poor and blind you have got
to cleanse me you have got to live
inside of me we have got to fight the
fight of faith and surrender every
moment so that he can dwell and live and
work in us nothing less than perfect
obedience can meet the standard of God's
requirement he has not left his
requirements indefinite the Savior took
upon himself the infirmities of humanity
and he lived a sinless life so that men
might have no fear that because of the
weakness of human nature they could not
overcome Christ came to make us
partakers of the divine nature and his
life declares that humanity combined
with divinity does not commit sin that's
1st John 3 verse 9 3 verse 9 that says
the exact same thing it says he that is
born of God does not commit sin because
God's seed remains in him hallelujah
I want to share something with you I'm
not I'm not telling you these things
because because it's up here I'm telling
you these things because I was so far
gone
there was no rescuing me and I tried so
hard to make things right and the harder
I tried the more it seemed like I got
behind and I kept searching especially
trying to comprehend what righteousness
by faith men and it was only within the
last few years that I thought that the
Lord and His mercy helped to open my
blind eyes God desires for each of us to
know who we are in Christ Jesus we say
it with our mouths but often we don't
believe it with our actions often we
don't understand what that means to be
in Christ Jesus the Bible says we are
his body his flesh and his bones when he
ascended on high he left us here as his
representatives not to strive and to do
in our own power but to surrender and
yield our lives completely to him so
that he can work in us just like his
father worked in him every moment as we
surrender and by faith we say your
righteousness is mine not because I feel
it but because you've spoken it you may
not feel victorious
but God's Word says were more than
conquerors through him that loves us so
do I believe what I'm feeling or do I
believe what the Word of God says you
may not feel healed if you've got some
type of a physical you know affliction
but God's Word says by my stripes
I have healed you and a quick example
when I was 14 years old I remember I
woke up one morning I was supposed to be
getting ready for school I felt like I
couldn't even move and I was burning up
hot I mean burning up and my mom finally
came in there she was like Eric what are
you doing I mean you gotta leave I got
to get you to school I said mom
something's wrong and she she knew then
something really was because I never
stayed home sick and she come over and
fell to me and she said you're burning
up and she called she's a nurse she
called our doctor and she said I've got
to get him in there and he said what's
wrong and she told him and they rushed
me the emergency room while I was in the
emergency room they were weighing me on
the scale and I passed out and wal was
passed out one of the nurses there she
had the wisdom that God did granted her
and she said let's check his blood sugar
it was 790 it's supposed to be 92 202
790 and I hadn't said anything to my mom
because I mean especially as a young man
you kind of want to just ignore problems
and say they'll go away I mean you know
it'll go away I don't know what's wrong
you know I was going to the restroom
every two or three minutes at school my
vision was almost completely God
couldn't even see the chalkboard at 14
years old I kept having to move closer
to the front of the class hoping nobody
would ask why I was trying to get closer
to the front and I got there to the the
doctor's office and when they woke me
if they told me something and I know
they were doing the best that they knew
how they said you're a diabetic and it's
juvenile and it'll never there is no
cure and you'll never get over it but if
you take this insulin we can keep you
alive well they didn't realize they were
pronouncing a curse upon me there is no
cure you'll never get better and all of
those things contradict the Word of God
and so I lived under that for a long
long time the the the curse and one day
I was speaking to a man and this was
after the Lord had brought me out of the
bondage I was in on these things and he
told me something he said Eric he said
if you had cancer would it be okay if I
called you cancer I was like no my name
is Eric he said well why couldn't I call
you cancer I said cuz it's just a
disease it's something I have it's not
who I am he said then why would you
allow people to call you a diabetic it's
a disease it's what you have it's not
who you are and I thought oh wow the
Bible says if we speak life we'll have
life so we have the power of life and
death in our tongue Ellen White says if
we speak faith we'll have faith and
faith is the substance of things hoped
for and the word hope in Greek does not
mean I hope so it means the things that
you have confidence in and the things
you have been given assurance of Ellen
White said if you speak faith you'll
have those things that you have
assurance that you've been given the
assurance of the Bible says that Christ
is the high priest of our profession
profession it means what you speak so
what I speak
he takes to the father so if I'm on my
knees and I'm like telling God about all
the affliction I have and I'm telling
God about how bad I feel and Lord I woke
up this morning and my blood sugar was
high and and Christ is up there and he's
going oh wow you know if I could just
get him to speak faith I would have a
much better prayer to offer to my father
so what I did was I started I started
reading God's promises out loud out loud
and I went in to a new doctor not gonna
get into that story but I went into a
new doctor never seen her before she's
brand new anyway she had to run blood
work through all these tests and she
called me a few days later she said
they're kinda I need you to come back
down to the the clinic I said what's
wrong and she said just want to run a
couple of more tests and I thought oh no
you know coz here I'd had this problem
for over 35 years and I got there and I
said what's wrong I said you know just
tell me and she said well Eric she said
all your paperwork says that you've had
juvenile diabetes since you were 14
years old she said but the blood work I
got when you came in here the other day
I couldn't even say that your juvenile
diabetes she said this looks more like
sort of on the verge of diabetes she
said your hemoglobin a1c is like six
point seven six point eight she said
normally to be juvenile it would have to
be like a seven one seven two she said I
want to run some more tests she ran some
tests and she came back and she said
your your pancreas is producing insulin
again she said this is impossible she
said you've had this for over 35 years
I've never seen anyone come in here
whose pancreas was producing insulin
after 35 years
now before I stop on the story I still
take insulin but I'm not taking nearly
what I was back then and what I have
found is is as I speak God's promises
out loud every day that I do that my
faith takes hold on those promises more
because now when I wake up in the
morning and if I check in my blood
Sugar's a little bit high instead of me
going and the devil whispers and usually
when he talks to us he talks in our
voice because if he came and he talked
in his voice I'd be like you know what
was that and I'd go get on my knees and
start praying normally when the devil or
one of his angels talks to you he'll
talk to you in your own voice because if
he can make you think it's your thoughts
you'll never fight him
so if I wake up in the morning and my
blood Sugar's a little bit high I'll
hear a voice that sounds like mine say
huh not healed yet God's true God's
words not true and I'm like okay he's a
liar right Jesus said that so what I do
is I go to God's Word and I say bless
the Lord O my soul and all that is
within me bless and praise His Holy Name
it is you who forgives all my iniquities
and heals all of my diseases and then I
claim Isaiah 53 by your stripes you said
it not me
you said it I am healed and then I claim
the same thing in Matthew 8 verse 17
through 19 and in 1st Peter says it 3
times in the scripture that at the mouth
of two or three witnesses every word
will be established by his stripes I am
healed you know it's funny too because
the Bible says the 144,000 will have
their father's name written in their
foreheads
what's our father's name I am I am
I am delivered I am saved not because I
feel it but because you said so in your
word I am healed I am more than
conquerors through him that loves me as
we speak faith God will work what he has
promised in our lives and when we look
at a loved one that looks like they're
so far gone that there's no hope of
recovering them I always remember what
my wife said about me when I was so far
gone and we had been divorced for five
years and I was living in adultery with
you know somebody else my wife the Lord
told her speak faith and she told my
children daddy's coming home and people
at church said you can't tell them that
they're gonna lose faith in God she said
God's Word said so God spoke that to me
and his word speak faith and you'll have
faith so when you look at a lost loved
one or you look at someone you're
praying for and it seems hopeless find
the promise in his word find the promise
in this word sometimes I struggled with
my children my sound of my daughter if
they're great they're great children I
mean great children but sometimes you
know as a parent what it's like when you
see them making mistakes that you go man
I've already done that don't make that
mistake so I would try to force them to
do the right thing and my wife would say
that's not gonna work just pray for them
I was like yeah but that's not gonna
work and she's like really I'm like okay
so I start claiming promises God you
promised and Deuteronomy 30 verse six
that you will circumcise my heart and
the heart of my children to love you
with all of our hearts our souls our
minds and our strength you promised and
I will not let you go except you bless
me that's the only way that we're going
to win there is no other way
let's close with prayer father in heaven
we thank you so much that you are not a
man that you should lie nor the son of
man that you should change your mind all
of your promises in Christ Jesus are yay
and all men father help each of us as we
open your word this week to find who we
are in Christ Jesus
[Music]